so let's get into some of these
talking points that i have over here i
think we're warmed up now
your circle of influence is going to
dictate your successes i think it's
fundamental for dudes to understand that
if you're going to surround yourself
with negative
whiny losers you surround yourself with
five
negative whiny losers you're gonna be
the sixth
there is no two ways about it if you're
allowing
these people into your life again i've
talked about this many many times
jack donovan's written some great books
about masculinity
tribalism the way of men is a is a good
starting point
you need to define your tribe you draw a
perimeter around it
and you have an us versus them strategy
you only let people in to your inner
circle
that have earned it that are deserved of
that placement
far too many guys let these
losers into their inner circle that
influence them
in a negative way and they think
sometimes that it's not going to have
any influence
i'll give you a good example there was
this there was this guy that
um i traveled in circles with
i'm going to say late 20s early 30s
um he had a bad drinking problem um
he was he was almost always drunk and he
was a really bad drunk
um he got involved in some other
uh compounds as well you know like weed
and stuff like that but that didn't
really affect him the way that alcohol
did
he was just really bad to be around
and it it made him almost intolerable to
be in public places with
he would have outbursts freak out you
know sometimes [ __ ] would break
sometimes he'd want to start a fight
with you come on fight me you know let's
you know come at me like you think
you're better than me sort of stuff like
that because
you didn't want to engage at his level
and he was always broke he was always
borrowing money from people
um you know he had hard time paying his
rent he had a hard time paying his staff
when he was
trying to run his business trying to
make money and anytime he came across
money it was gone boom it was it just
evaporated just like that
and i let this guy uh
orbit my inner perimeter you know get on
the inside
for far too long mostly because i was
really good friends with
with one guy that went to uh high school
with him
and uh you know he cleaned himself up
this other guy he you know he got
himself
um out of his vices out of his
addictions went through a.a
was completely sober and clean for a
number of years he was a good guy you
know he was
you know he's doing the work in life he
was leveling up he lost a ton of body
fat he was like this
he was like this um short kind of
not even pudgy but like fat dude with a
bad haircut he had this like
big bad haircut sort of thing and he
cleaned it all up man he turned into a
good looking dude got himself a decent
job made some money
drove a nice car lost all the fat we
you know by the end of it when i uh came
to know him as he cleaned himself up
um you know we started calling him
pocket hercules at the office because we
used to work together he was this little
dude that was all just like buff as [ __ ]
but this other guy that used to travel
in circles
he just brought us down man everything
that we did there was there was always
some
something that was that was invited into
our life just by having this guy around
us
i remember one time we were sitting
around um i think this is um
you know like late 20s or so this is in
the halo days with the xbox one you know
like the original one
and i remember you know he came in the
house and um
he looked all sketchy and dodgy sort of
thing like that and we're like
what's up a dude right and he just kind
of like ran off and kind of hit in a
corner and then
a few few seconds later there was a
police officer at the door there there's
two of them it's like
every turn of the way it was like there
was there was
there was no surprise that it was coming
and it wasn't that he was a bad guy
he was a good guy he had a good heart um
you know he was he was
fun to be around when he was clean and
focused and
attentive to getting [ __ ] done but he
just
he was just intolerable and it just got
to the point where i just cut him out
and had i let him and maybe other people
that he you know he got involved with
because there was always somebody that
he would
uh collaborate with or associate with
that he would bring over to our place
and
he'd also get smashed or stoned out of
his mind and trip over something and
start breaking things in the house and
they just
i remember one time he uh you know
he tried to get in the house and we
weren't back from the club yet and
because he was pissed off and drunk out
of his mind he
ripped the screen door off the front of
the house this is the house that we
rented by the way
you rip the screen door off the front of
the house and just kind of let it left
it hang in there
you know if you if you allow these
people into your life
and i've done this if you allow these
people into your life they're going to
hold you back
i've said this before we have people
that are
sales that will fill our sales with wind
and air and and
drive us forward and we have people that
are anchors and anchors hold you back
and it's funny that i keep mentioning
this because i keep watching so many
sailing videos on youtube now but
uh you got to cut those anchors loose
man you know they
they hold you back you you can only
permit people into your life and the
sooner that you learn this lesson
honestly i wish i learned this lesson in
my 20s because it would have saved me a
lot of time and a lot of stupid choices
and decisions
uh spending time with or surrounding
myself with people that
you know didn't have that that didn't
want to level up
that didn't want me to level up that
didn't want to level up themselves they
just wanted to be
mediocre and that's fine there's people
like that but once you identify
them you gotta let them go you have to
cut them loose
there's no two ways about it and that
might mean that you're gonna have to cut
loose you know
friends that you were you know hanging
out with in high school for the longest
time
you know the the good friend of mine
that was clean
that had to separate himself from this
guy had a really struggled with it
because he was good friends with him
throughout the high school and he had a
lot of history together and all sort of
stuff
um you have to be able to do that man
you know when you know when people do
that to you um
and they really let you down in that
sense you got to let them go and
and there's and there should be nothing
that um
that that is off the table you know if
i'm being honest
um when i was in my
i want to say second or third year
running my debt business in my early 30s
um i ended up getting into a serious
problem with
well ultimately what was my best friend
of like you know 25 30 years
or you know something like that at that
point it was 25 years and um
you know he was he was living in my
house actually rescued this guy
from his shitty relationship with a
single mommy um i remember his mom
called me
from the states to beg me to have him
stay there and i was okay with that
because he was a good friend of mine he
was
um you know he was he was there for me
but um
he just he just went down the shitty
path of like greed man
and started collaborating with like
really really bad guys i got heavily
involved in like
uh you know cocaine like really bad
drugs and stuff like that
and it was all about money and the
friendship
took a backseat you know like it used to
be bros all the time like
you know my brother and i ended up
having to sue the guy and cut him loose
and the stupid thing was was he deserved
everything that he got and then after
all that
dude had the balls to like come at me
later on and like you know
maybe we can patch us up and water under
the bridge we'll just forget the salt no
you gotta ghost people like that
they are done once they prove once they
show when somebody shows you who they
really are
it's incumbent upon you to let them go
to cut those [ __ ] loose from your
life
they're out there and i know right now
there's people watching this broadcast
right that are thinking themselves yeah
i know
one maybe two maybe five guys you know
in their in their inner circle that are
problematic for them you gotta cut those
guys loose man gotta cut them loose
your your circle of influence is always
gonna dictate
the limits to your success
the more that i surround myself with
focused intentional good
people which didn't really happen until
my 30s
my life improved significantly
leaps and bounds i stopped allowing
loser women into my life
i stopped allowing loser friends into my
life i stopped
getting involved with people that i
should never be involved with
that are tremendously problematic for
guys being successful you know like i
always say guys it's
it's incumbent upon you as a man you you
have the burden of performance
you